being the acting returning officer the
election of the Member of Parliament for
the Plymouth Sutton and Devonport
constituency held on the 8th of June
2017 do hereby declare that the number
of votes cast was as follows
Danny bambam ping independent 213
Henriette Sarah bewdley Liberal Democrat
1106 Oliver Newton Colville the
Conservative Party candidate 17,000 806
Richard Michael Ellison UK Independence
Party you Kip 1148 Luke Pollard labour
and cooperative party 23,000
done
Daniel Michael sheep the green party 540
the number of rejected ballot papers was
83 and I therefore declare the Luke
Pollard is duly elected as the Member of
Parliament for blim earth Sutton and
Devonport constituency
thank you hello Plymouth Plymouth has
its voice back in Parliament I'm proud
of Plymouth I'm proud to been been born
here proud to live here and now I'm very
proud to be a member of parliament here
I want to thank the people of Plymouth
off in Devonport for putting their trust
in me to be their MP I especially want
to thank all those people who voted
labour and voted for the very first time
we've seen so many young people in
particular put their trust in politics
casting their ballot for a better City
and I'll say thank you to them
now it's traditional this point that I
thank the police and the and the
counting staff I would like to thank
them for keeping us safe and for
speeding through the count tonight thank
you I'd also like to thank Oliver
Colville for his service to our city
I look forward to working with Oliver on
the effective handover of casework to
make sure that everyone that's got in
touch with a member of parliament gets
the care and attention that they need
but the campaign for better schools and
better NHS in Plymouth begins now
my campaign our campaign to extend the
m5 from Exeter to Plymouth begins now
our campaign to reopen Plymouth Airport
begins now our campaign for a cruise
terminal and Mill Bay begins now our
campaign for proper costed investment in
our railway begins now
and so does the campaign to make sure
that Plymouth Sound is designated as the
UK's first national marine park but
there's something else I want to give
notice to Plymouth Tory MPs each time
you vote against Plymouth best interests
I will be there to expose you I will be
there to fight for Plymouth
Lillith deserves a better deal we
deserve our fair share and the fight for
our fair share begins today thank you
Plymouth thank you
[Applause]